Can I please tell you what my favorite part
about my most recent appearance in court was?
Two people who don't like me
try to conspire against me and get me in trouble,
like, get me in jail,
and they don't like each other.
It was actually the gentleman who smashed my car.
Thought he was gonna be so fucking cute and link up, link up
and try to hurt me. And. Oh,
oh, not.
Sorry to say, it actually worked in my benefit.
Because when you're fucking idiot
and you're doing things with ugliness in your fucking heart,
it shows. So I'm good.
I'm fucking great, actually.
I can't tell you the last time I've been better,
actually. I'm fucking on cloud 999.
Keep motherfucking keeping on.